Every kid loves music.
The idea of this is, "Why does it have to be just after school?"
"Why not enjoy it in school?"
A young person can tell you more about who they are through their music...
...than through anything else.
My favorite classes are the ones that help me in my everyday life...
...because they have something to do with your life.
The whole idea is to connect thoughts using the popular music of whatever period of time,...
...to connect to what was happening historically.
The thing that really resonated for me and Steven's original conception was that...
...we wanted to study this musical context.
We wanted to see that this was much more than entertainment.
They're learning from that music.
This curriculum is really an opportunity to take that learning...
...and bring it to a whole other level.
So if you want students to be successful,...
...you as the teacher, as the educator, have to go to where they are at.
And music is such a big part of where they are at.